James Corden and wife Julia Carrie  welcomed a baby girl I find it  absolutely incredible the whole thing  the 39 year old late night host took to  social media to announce the exciting  news Julia gave birth to their third  child on Tuesday tweeting today we  welcomed a beautiful baby daughter into  the world both she and her mother are  doing great we can't stop smiling I've  never seen anything like it  James also hinted that his good friend  Harry Styles would be taking over  hosting duties on Tuesday nights The  Late Late Show quote Thank You Harry for  stepping in to host the show at two and  a half hours notice xxx the couple's new  bundle of joy joins six-year-old Big  Brother Max and three-year-old sister  Carrie we told them that we were gonna  have another addition to our family in  the exact same place that I proposed to  my wife in London and it was great they  you know they're excited  [Music]